ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเปิด
ค่ะเรียนทุกๆคนนะก็คือมาเจอกับเรา 2 คน
อีกแล้วใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้า
แล้วหามาเจอกับผู้ฟ้ารูหญิงในบิ๊กเกอร์
Class ป๋าไปแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
วันอังคารวันอังสานวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันอังคารที่ 15 ค่ะค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพตอะไรคะปีพต 2  565
อุ้ยดีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 14 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับผมฟ้าพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
ค่ะ
วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ ๑๖
๑๖ เดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตค
อีก 5 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะ 2022 เนาะแล้วตอนนี้ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูบา
สิงห์โมง 35 นาทีค่ะครูหญิง
นี่เนาะ 10 โมง 35 นาทีนะคะก็เป็นเวลา
กลางวันเนาะกลางวันเป็นตอนกลางวันลองขาย
ของผู้หญิงได้กี่โมงคะ
ของครูหญิงสวยของครูหญิงเนี่ย
10:00 นอ่ะ 10:00 น 35 นาที
2 ครูหญิงเวลากลางคืนของครูฟ้ากลางวัน
ตัวของผู้หญิงเนี่ยกลางคืนโหเวลาเนี่ยตรง
ข้ามกันนะคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นใช่ไหมครูหญิงเนี่ยนอนนะ
คะนอน
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมคะเพราะเขาอะไรอะไรดีค่ะ
ค่ะแข็งแรงจังหวัดกินได้กินได้นอนได้ครู
ฟ้าล่ะคะสบายดีไหมคะสบายดีค่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ย
โอเคสบายดีไม่มีโควิช
โอเคแข็งแรงเลยแล้วก็
มีความสุขดี
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยทั้งหมดสบายดีใช่ไหมคะมาคือ
สบายดีหัวโอเคหัว
ฮะโอเค
หนูโอเค
หูโอเคค่ะจมูกโอเคจมูก
โอเคตึ่งปากโอเคป่าโอเคปั้น
โอเค
ฟันโอเคค่ะปลาล่ะตาโอเคไหมคะ
ตาเหรอคะ
โอเคนะ
ก็โอเคนะว่าครูสากับผู้หญิงอ่ะใส่แว่นตา
ใช่ไหมนี่เราสองคนเนี่ยมีแว่นตาใส่แว่นตา
สมัยก็ตาก็โอเคแต่ถ้าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
เนี่ยถอดแว่นตา
ไม่ใส่แว่นตา
ตาโอเคไหมคะครูฟ้าดูได้ไหมถ้ากูฟ้าไม่ขอ
แว่นตา
ไม่โอเคค่ะคุณหญิง
มองชายดูดวงอะไรไม่เห็นอาน้องเฮ้ยครูหญิง
กับครูฟ้าก็เลยต้องใส่แว่นตาไว้ใส่แว่นตา
ก็จะได้ดูได้มองเห็น
ยุคต้องค่ะใส่แว่นตาเนี่ยโอเค
ถอดแว่นไม่โอเคนักเรียนไม่ได้นะคอร์ด
เนี่ย
หมอไม่
ดูไม่ได้สมัยต้องใส่แว่นตาแนวเพราะว่าตา
ของเราเนี่ยเอาไว้ดูสมัยดูนักเรียนนัก
เรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยอะดู YouTube สมัยดู
วีดีโอของครูหญิงครูฟ้าก็ต้องใช้ตาไม่ใช้
ตาดู
ไทยค่ะหน้าหมูนั่นแหละรูปผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็
เลยวันนี้ก็เลยมีคำถามสวยฮะมีคำถามนะคำ
ถาม
ถามว่าอะไรคะครูหญิงมีคำถามว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีตาใช่ไหมครูหญิงมีตาแล้วก็ดูครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยชอบดูอะไร
ครูฟ้าชอบดูอะไร
ครูฟ้าชอบดูทีวีไหมคะ
เพราะว่าที่บ้านครูขวาเนี่ยน่าจะมีชีวี
PB น้องอันนี้คือ TV นะคะครูฟ้าชอบดู
ทีวีไหมคะครูฟ้าชอบดูทีวีไหมมือไม่ชอบดู
ทีวีอ้าวครูฟ้าไม่ชอบดูคุณครูฟ้าก็ไม่ดู
ทีวีได้กูฟ้าก็ไม้ดูทีวีไม่รู้ทีใจกูฟ้า
เนี่ยแม่ทีวีไม่ชอบเอ้าแล้วผู้ฟ้าชอบดู
อะไรคะ
ครูฟ้าชอบดู
ซีรีส์ในเน็ต L อ๋อ
ฟ้า 10 ดูซีรีส์เอาแล้วครูฟ้าดูซีรีส์ที่
ไหนครูฟ้าไม่ได้ดูสิรี่ที่ทีวีหรอคะไม่
ได้ดูซีรีส์ทีวีฟ้าไม่ได้ดูซีรีส์ที่ทีวี
ค่ะว่าทีวีเนี่ยจะเป็นต่อมเคเบิลทีวี
มีไวตี้มีอะไรในทีวีฟ้าก็ไม่ดูทีวีฟ้าก็
เลยดูซีรีส์ใน
ขอเบอร์
เฮอะ of ครูฟ้ามีคอมพิวเตอร์
ไปหากแบบ Top เหรอ Notebook เหมือนกันไหม
คะเอาไม่หามีคอมพิวเตอร์
คอมพิวเตอร์ดีมั้ย
คอมพิวเตอร์เป็นคอมพิวเตอร์เลยใช่ไหมอ๋อ
กูฟ้ามีคอมพิวเตอร์ตั้งโต๊ะ
ไหนอ่ะฟ้าก็คือมีคอมพิวเตอร์เดี๋ยวใช่ไหม
ซึ่งว่าคอมพิวเตอร์แบบนี้ล่ะค่ะ
อายไปคอมพิวเตอร์มันใหญ่เลยโอเคนะดู
ซีรีส์โอเคหรือบางทีก็ดูใน Notebook ก็มี
ค่ะอ๋อโอเคว่าไอแพดค่ะเนี่ยในแก้
ไอเอคุณครูฟ้าก็ดูซีรีส์ที่
คอมพิวเตอร์
วิเตอร์ Notebook หรือว่า iPad จะมันก็
ไม่ได้ดูทีวีไม่ได้ดูทีวีเพราะว่าฟ้ามี
คุณแม่ใช่ไหมค่ะนะฮะ
ก็
พระครูสาอยู่บ้านไงใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าอยู่บ้าน
อยู่บ้าน
ชายว่าก็มีคุณแม่ค่ะคุณแม่อะชอบดูทีวี
หาหมอแล้วครูฟ้าก็ก็ครูฟาร์มไม่ดูทีวีกับ
คุณแม่เหรอคะ
ไปหาแบบ
อันนี้ครูฟ้าสวยครูฟ้าแล้วก็คุณแม่เมื่อ
สองคน
ดูทีวีหรือป่าวไหมดูทีวีกับคุณแม่มาอย่า
บอกว่าไม่ดูทีวีกับแม่นะคะว่าจักอ่ะแม่
เนี่ยชอบดู
ซีรีส์
ไม่เหมือนครูฟ้า
น้ำ
ก็อีกกินข้าวเน็ตเหล็กเหมือนกันนะคะ
ซีรีส์เน็ททริกซ์แม่ก็ดูซีรี่ย์เน็ตฟิก
ใช่ไหมแต่ดูเนี่ยไม่เหมือนกันกูบอกซีรีส์
แปลว่าอีกแบบนึงการ์ตูนอนิเมะคุณแม่อาจจะ
ดูซีรีส์แบบหนึ่งอ๋ออ๋อก็ก็เลยแยกใช่ไหม
คุณแม่ดูทีวีครูป๋าดูซีรีส์ที่
คอมพิวเตอร์
แล้วเวลาครูฟ้าดูซีรีส์เนี่ยครูฟ้าดู
ซีรีส์ตอนไหนคะตอนและรางวัลจะไปตอนกลาง
วันหรือว่าตอนกลางคืนกูฟ้าดูตอนไหน
บางทีก็ดูตอนกลางวันนะคะเพราะว่าตอนกลาง
วันเนี่ยจะดูซีรีส์เวลากินข้าวขอ
กินข้าวค่ะถ้ากินข้าวเสร็จก็ปิดไม่ดู
ซีรีส์เออแล้วตอนกลางคืนน่ะตอนกลางคืนก็
ดูซีรีส์เหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะใช่หาตอนกลาง
คืนก็ดูซีรีส์หะชอบดูซีรีส์ตอนกลางคืน
หนึ่งก็ดูซีรีส์ตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยชอบมากเออ
เพราะตอนกลางคืนกินเขา
ครูขวาเนี่ยดูซีรีส์สมัยเน็ทฟลิกแล้วครู
ฟ้าดู
ใช่ไหมคะ
ครูฟ้าฟ้าดู YouTube ค่ะ
ครูฟ้าดูอะไรที่ YouTube อ่ะ
ลูกฟ้าดู
เอ่อแชทเกมค่ะอ๋อเหมือนฟิล์มวิ่งเกมแล้ว
หรอถ้าอยากครับ
มันจะเป็นไม่ใช่ Streaming แต่ว่าเป็นเกม
แบบแคสเกมใช่ไหมสมมติว่าจะเปิดให้ดูนะแบบ
นี้มีคอมพิวเตอร์ใช่ไหมคอมพิวเตอร์เกมนี้
หรอคะแล้วก็
แคสเกม
พวกเสียเถอะ
คุณผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่รู้จักนะขอ
เกมแบบนี้อ้ะ
หืองู
คือ 1 วีดีโอใช่มะมาถึงวีดีโอเนี่ยวิดีโอ
YouTube เนี่ยหนึ่งมากกว่า
มากกว่า 40 นาทีเนาะใช้เหมือนเป็นแบบว่า
Movie มั้ยหัวเป็น Movie เลยอ่ะ
สุขมากกูบอกว่าเลยชอบนะคะแล้วก็บัญชีเก็บ
แบบเป็นเกมที่มี Sorry จะมี sorry  for
ก็จะนั่งดูเหมือนดูซีรีส์อ่ะ
แต่ว่าเป็นดูแคสเกมใน YouTube เลยมาเล่น
เกมใน YouTube ค่ะก็
ดูวีดีโอ SM  R ออก
แล้วดูฟ้าดูอะไรที่ YouTube อีก
ดู
asmr
ทำอะไรคะกินหรอกิน add  a  SMS มา
ยืนอยู่ใช่แบบอย่างเงี้ย
ไหนคะอ๋อ
ผู้หญิงไม่ดูผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไม่ดูเหรอไม่
ดูผู้หญิงเนี่ยไม่ดูวีดีโอ YouTube  a  s
m อากินได้แบบเวลาดูมันต้องดูใช่ไหมแล้ว
บางครั้งก็ฟังด้วยแต่เวลาดูมีคนเนี่ยกิน
ได้ YouTube เนี่ยคุยเวอร์
โอเคไปโอเคไปดู
แต่ผู้ค้าจะดูเป็นแบบอย่างนี้เยอะมากกว่า
เนี่ยเป็น
เหมือนเป็น asm อาร์มนะว่าเป็นเมคอัพ
ต่อแบบดูด้วยฟังเสียงด้วยไม่ใช่ไหมคะอะไร
อ่ะ
มันแบบนี้โอเคนะครับก็สบายสบาย
ไปสบาย
แล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูซีรีส์ใช่ไหมคะดูยูทูป
ครูความดูหนังมั้ย
ดูหนังหรอคะ
จะมีเปิดให้ดูนะถ้าไม่อาจจะแบบ
หนัง
ดูน
มีอุ้ยอันนี้ไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ YouTube นะคะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เน็ต
ฟลิกซ์นะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่ Left  4 หน้า
อย่างนี้ใช่ไหมอย่างแรกวีโดอย่างเงี้ยก็
เป็นหนังหนังฮอลลีวู๊ดภาษา Spider หรือ
ว่าเออใส่สไปเดอร์แมนหรือว่าอันนี้อะอัน
ชาร์ตเต็ดอะไรเนี่ยก็เป็นหนังใช่ไหมหนัง
เนี่ยไม่ได้ดูที่บ้านอ่ะแต่ถ้าเราอยู่ที่
บ้านนะแล้วดูอันนี้ไม่ใช่หนักเนาะหนัง
เนี่ยต้องไปดูที่อื่นหรือดูหนังนี่เนี้ย
ดูหนังก็ต้องไปดูที่โรงไหนใช่ไหมคะ
เจอไหมคะผู้หญิง
โรงหนัง
หน้าแล้วนี้นะคะนักเรียน
อันนี้เนาะอันนี้คือที่ที่โรงหนังสมัยโรง
หนังเวลาเราไปดูหนัง
สถานหนังนานแล้วก็อาจจะดูที่ Streaming
ก็ได้ให้อ่ะครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูซีรีส์จะไม่ครู
ฟ้าดูหนังไหมคะดูหนังหาคู่ฟ้าชอบคุณถังนะ
คะว่างไปโรงหนังใช่ไหมไปโรงหนังไปดูน่ะ
ค่ะ
จะดูหนังแล้วก็ไปดูหนังอ่ะอ่าว่าชอบไปโรง
หนังต้องบอกว่าชอบไปดูหนังที่โรงหนังนี่
ค่ะสมัยนี้เป็นจอแล้วก็ครูฟ้านั่งอยู่ที่
ที่นี่แล้วก็ดู
ไม่ปลาชอบไปดูหนังที่โรงหนังอ่ะเขาว่าปลา
ชอบกินป๊อกปอนด์นะคะ
ขอที่โรงหนังในเวลาดูหนังก็กิน
กินป๊อปคอร์นไปด้วยกันดูหนังดูด้วยกิน
ด้วย
เนี่ยคือที่ประเทศไทยมันก็จะมีป๊อปคอร์น
ไม่ตอนนี้เอา
ล่ะโป๊ะพร
อย่างดีรอยก็คนในโรงหนักค่ะฟ้า
อย่าท้อกินโพนมากนะโชว์ 6 มากก็เลยชอบดู
หนังๆก็เลยชอบไปดูหนังน่ะอ๋อก็ว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยชอบดูซีรีส์
ดู YouTube แล้วก็ก็ดูหนังสมัยคะถูกต้อง
ค่ะก็
มีดูการ์ตูนกันนะ
ฝาจะดูดูดูการ์ตูนอะไรคะ Disney หรอ
มิกกี้เมาส์มินนี่เมาส์
โดนัลด์ดั๊ก
อะไรนะดูวินนี่เดอะพูห์สมัยเป็นการ์ตูน
ดูการ์ตูนดูการ์ตูน
การ์ตูนโคนันหรือว่า
อาร์ม
การ์ตูนดูการ์ตูนอะไรอีกอ่ะ
The  demon สด
โห App แท็กออนไททัน
บ่
ว่าบะหมี่อ่ะ
การ์ตูน
อันนี้มันเป็นคะก็ดูอะไรอีกคะคนไทยอาจจะ
พูดว่าอะนิเมะ
ๆก็อาจจะเป็นการ์ตูนอนิเมะบางคนนี้กว่าดู
การ์ตูนว่าไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เราเล่นนะเป็น
การ์ตูนใช่ไหมคะว่าก็ครูฟ้าก็ชอบดู
การ์ตูน
คือชอบดูการ์ตูนค่ะค่ะ
นี่แหละก็ดูซีรีส์ครับดูนะกลัวฟ้าเนี่ยดู
ซีรีส์ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ดูอะไรนะคะ YouTube
เอไอเอสวิวาห์
แต่ก็ Cat เองดูหนังดูการ์ตูน
แต่ครูฟ้าถ้าไม่ดูเกมส์โชว์วาไรตี้โชว์
ไม่ดูหรอไม่ดูให้ดูอีกทีไม่ดูเกมส์ชู้ขอ
ขอทรายอันนี้ก็เป็นที่ครูฟ้าใช่มั้ยชอบดู
นะคะนักเรียนชอบดูอะไร
เขาเป็นบอกเราได้ชอบดูเหมือนครูฟ้าไหมก็
ถามเม้นบอกเราได้นะคะนี่หรือว่านักเรียน
หมอชอบดูยูทูปครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
ไม่ดีค่ะพี่
น้องก็วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวมาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าเนาะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะ 555
[เพลง]